thank you
all right hello and welcome everyone
this is the course active inference for
the social sciences in 2023. it's August
30th or maybe a different date depending
on where you are
and today we're in the semiotics and
semantics section we'll be hearing a
lecture from Lorena zakenzela and then
we're going to have a little bit of a
discussion so Lorena thank you a lot for
joining and off to you for the lecture
okay
hello everyone
um I'm based in Australia yeah I'm
Lorena I'm doing actually my PhD in
philosophy here
I'm working cognitive sciences and
philosophy I work within from Concepts
or Innovations of information
so I'm very interested in
um foundational understanding of
cognitive sciences and information and
how this this kind of things cash out
and this is why I was interested in
talking about semantics and social
cognition
to see how these things cash out and
have a few ideas on how semiotics
can be compatible with like active
imprints and I try to organize a little
bit of this semiotic notion and active
inference to see if they pan out maybe
they don't so let's see how he goes
um
so let's talk about active inference
formal semantics and social cognition
foreign
okay I cannot move my slides now we can
so
I will first have a very short
introduction for you guys I have out
here so what you're going to do like we
have a short introduction I'm going to
talk a little bit of theories of meaning
and then we're gonna talk a little bit
the free energy principle and active
inference uh and how shared symbols and
social cognition can be thought together
I bring one case that I find interesting
and then we draw some conclusions
so let me know what you think in the
comments and after we can have a little
discussion or in the next session
so
your background introduction that I want
to first point to is we're talking about
biological agents and how they act so
we're always thinking in terms of
biological agents acting to express
uh you know that Express information or
sensitivities to context dependent
relevance to their environment and
things
uh that involve communities however how
this very minimal way of talking about
what motivates and what is relevant to
people becomes stable enough as a
self-sustaining pattern
of interactions like are they stable and
how they become that stable soon how can
those information sensitivities ground
values norms and goals like consistently
and over time
assuming that those values and goals are
necessary for Meaningful interactions so
we have two line motivations to behavior
right that's not really obvious and
ultimately how meaning is brought about
I don't think I'm gonna answer that but
I want to point to some directions and
how people have been thinking about
these questions over time
uh
so the problem of meaning has a brief
account right like traditionally
approaches of uh
to cognition localized meaning inside
individual organisms and more
specifically inside their minds so
meaning pertains to
a bit of content and this kind of things
so many have however like many have a
developmental history so it's hard to
catch those two things together if it's
inside people's minds how it can have an
evolutionary in developmental history
assuming that meanings are same things
that we can learn over time and they
happen in shared contexts they don't
happen out of nowhere in a vision from
nowhere
in a sense like we can say that it's not
really trivial the
conventionalized words
like for example meaning the
conventionalized meaning of a word for
instance cat means catch have
evolutionary history one thing does not
come from the other we need a better
understanding to Cache this meaning out
and that's where I'm stepping from like
that's my grounding like you need to
catch these things out in terms of
community of language users
which brings a problem right we have
goals and values that can be defined in
terms of those communities and you have
material and body factors so how these
two things are together or how how goals
and values affect and
motivate to material and envirage agents
to answer this kind of question like
over time there are a few
preferred ways like some I will do a
brief overview of some theories of
meaning they usually in terms of
cognitive sciences and any philosophy of
mind that's what I'm interested in how
they catch it out they usually try to
think of those things in terms of syntax
like concerns with form as an abstract
organizing kind of approval it's a type
of grammar and how uh at the order of
things and how The Logical
unfolding of those symbols how they
become meaningful and we but the syntax
itself is not really enough to cash out
meaning in semantics so then
in that since syntax evolve into a field
that we call semantics in which meaning
and mental constant are organized
throughout this
instructional syntax
then we have prepositional knowledge and
Truth conditions in which allows
these organizational story of meaningful
words to make sense and they're going to
point out into the into the outside
world
and I have a third option it's an it's
not so news well it's not so famous
which is semantics or more importantly I
will focus on bio semantics
uh they uses it concerns with the use of
symbols like
how they bring about meaning in terms of
pragmatics and that would be a little
bit different and we'll catch it out in
different terms
in relation to its peers like semantics
and syntax
well syntax is pretty clear in terms of
being rules right so what is semantics
talk about so talk about mental content
about intentionality about mental
representations in the sense we have
semantics that have a specific key
Concepts that reference truth conditions
and denotation so if you have mental
content and if you put these meanings
inside the organism it has to refer to
something else and how this cognitive
penetratory penetration happens like how
can meaning
come about Inside the Mind and how that
refers
to something outside in the world and
how this observational Viewpoint of you
thinking about something in front of you
can be actually true so we need we need
true conditions that denote these
specific relationship
and that is represented like in terms of
mental content
foreign
ly there's like very ways of catching
this out like uh it can that can be
functional that can be more an
internalized mental specific types of
representations grounded in vehicles
it's a very rich discussion and I don't
want to go into all that but just want
to point it out that science and
Neuroscience use those terms to study
and to build models that relates to
mental representations in terms of newer
representations because it kind of makes
sense for us like brain activity you can
see them in terms of what happens
by studying human beings and babysitting
animals and how this make the
representations really to something that
happens in the world you can see that
one Behavior elicits specific
activities and they have a correlational
uh relationship
and that is highly debated but there we
go we have
many types of Cashing Out newer
representations and concerning to this
relationship of stimuli and the
interpretation of the stimuli and how
they
motivate action
that's already a very much weaker claim
in relation to mental content and things
being inside organisms but it is to you
in the same line of reasoning
and there is also biosemite semiotics
which I want to focus a little bit more
because it comes in with the use and
interpretation of signs and symbols
which then also emphasizes like the
nature the embodied nature and the
situated nature of meaning so you don't
have meaning without those practices and
without the use of embodied agents
so we have to reject the idea that
meaning are abstract symbols or they
kind of be something that has to be in
your mind and refer to something outside
they're gonna only exist in this type of
relationship and they can take many
forms including chemical signal signals
like visual Clues Behavior words
like the word catch you can have
and how you organize it will get they
are all symbolic and that fits also in
that kind of structure
so they are very important for
communication obviously because we do
communicate in terms of pointing to the
same shared Notions of symbols in words
and also other types of of symbolic
meaning
and we coordinate life around them so
living systems are then here
characterized by the semiotics
but the ability of creating and
interpreting and using these symbols in
terms of their practices the fathers
like of biosemiotics
and started like in
about probably in the 19th century
and Ox coal is one of the most famous
Representatives currently you can find
new
authors like Hoffman or
bigger
so I try to organize a little bit
in a specific model uh in a type of
model in a visual story how this uh two
types of understanding many are being
applied in terms of
series of reading
historically so even by semiotics we
have into pragmatics and you have the
practice and they relate to Dynamics and
context dependent so you can see here on
the top of the screen how agent we have
the agent relationship with its
psychological and social aspects and by
semiotics is somewhat concerned of how
correlation leads to prediction and
beliefs and that leads to expectations
and we also have other types of theories
likewise tele semantics and um
and theories of computational syntax
that tries to understand the Dynamics
and the mechanism of these uh
relationship
and they are not really Crossing each
other they are not in the same
they're not talking about the same
necessary things so how can these things
be brought together
that's when we I was thinking how can
bring this
free energy principle and active
inference in terms of those
relationships so well
different every principle and active
active influence as we know and I have
been talking about probably in the past
two classes they have it's a model that
is interesting for that because it has
like very minimal assumptions so it
starts off from the idea that organisms
act to maintain themselves in their
expected biological and cognitive States
so you're always talking you're you're
modeling and you're using this
mathematical to ground uh biological
agents in very embodied sense
and they do so by minimizing the free
energy right so they have these
metabolical states that have to be
minimized in terms of
expenditure in terms of uncertainty
given that
the long-term average of free energy is
entropy they want to minimize their
uncertainty in terms of their
metabolical states well that that
entails
that they have a specific range of
States they want to stay in like
minimally just stay alive to stay alive
you have to do a bunch of
things as a human being but every single
embodied agent would you prefer to stay
alive so there are some preferred basic
states that we've defined how action
will be take first to maintain it
metabolical states and how that
coordinates with the environment
which entities that
organisms and agents can be described in
in those terms like in active inference
tries to bring out those minimals
assumptions in mathematical terms that
try to express how reducing the
probability of these non-anticipated
states or States they are not favorable
to maintaining the minimum metabolical
needs
will be reduced right and that can be
catch the in terms of a generative model
as we've been saying throughout the best
actions how this genetic model set
specific times and organizes around
specific parameters that wants to they
can be described as trying to maintain
those parameters within reasonable uh
range
so by minimizing free energy on average
and over time this system will
self-organize so we'll bring out the
parameters of its internal states that
occupy a limited number of possible
State through set into a specific range
that will then be
then we'll be
used as somewhat could be in the guide
for this Behavior you have two kinds of
Dynamics happening here right that's
what I want to talk about a little bit
so we have then a phenotype that exists
in a specific type of States but that
will have to coordinate two different
kinds of Dynamics they're going to be
stated here as complement complementary
right you have both plates you have
belief updated so with Flow State you
have one type of modeling which is the
normal equilibrium steady states that is
intrinsic is named here intrinsic
information geometry and you have
believed updating that can be
can be treated as
extrinsic information on Geometry and
those are different
types of modeling
or the different types of thinking about
those processes that's most important
right so in terms of flow States
we can talk about uh dynamical system
and how you settle and self-organize
specific parameters and in terms of
failure updating we will be talking
about by Asian mathematics and by Asian
cognitive cognition and in in specific
ways of catching out
how an agent will change and behave over
time in relation to the Dynamics that
is set into place in this like State
space of possible actions
so while dynamical systems will explore
temporary contextual dependence between
environment and agent will set these
specific State space that has temporal
Dimension and has contextual Dimension
and once this state space is sort of
established we have more or less
uh it's a more
more or less
deterministic approach
to what what can possibly unfold so how
changes changes in how Behavior
can be cashed out in terms of
non-deterministic behavior and that is
defined by the different type of
probabilistic
thinking
which is division mechanics of belief or
belief updating so we have then a
process of belief updating throughout
weighted interactions within this range
of
possible
States
so we do have Dynamics and we do also
have by Asian process
unfolding together in terms of
mechanisms
and with that we do have mathematical
statements providing a unifying
perspective on formal approaches
connecting behavior and Dynamics
so that's what active inference should
be bringing about as a novelty in
relation to other forms of understanding
organisms which can also can either cash
things out in terms of behavior or in
terms of Dynamics so trying to bring
these two things together is quite
interesting to understand how symbols
and what is semantics for instance
so that's what that's the question I
will be asking right now let's talk a
little bit about that
I'm drawing here from a quite
interesting paper from
Maxwell hamster and initi politics
um
is in is free energy principle a
principle for formal semantics
so what what would be formal semantics
it sounds like
an oxymoron right like how semantics can
be formal how can you formalize it so
semantics the theory of meaningful
things so how can that be empty of
content
well
it has a few principles in which you can
explain what performance semantics
should how a formal semantics should be
understood
first off we have by Asian formalism
that does not necessarily have to commit
to classical Notions or representations
which are propositional in nature have
propositional semantic Concepts so the
idea is that you can
you can use the notion of representation
in a way that is not necessarily
contentful so how that's going to be
so under the free energy principle
representations can be formal that's the
argument
they are bringing under the physics of
uh flow specifically dynamical system
theories and information geometry you
can have this mathematical statements
that only represent possible uh
specific ways of interacting how these
correlations will affect each other in
over time in this variational phase type
of
Cashing Out mathematical uh functions
in the sense we can talk about
representation you know how we can be
understood under this formalism and what
they are saying is that they are best
understood as internal structures that
enable the system to parse out their
sensory sensitivities or the sensory
streams so to organize them in specific
parameters and also in terms of their
own Market of blankets and in their
blanket States
which is interesting here which is the
new novelty of this paper is that ground
in a mathematical model in these
mathematical properties of the system
will like avoid grounding these
properties in terms of the properties of
symbols and semantics in abstract or
subjective Notions of meaning but
impossible ranges of action
so summing up what we had before was a
type of computational model that had a
specific components that does not allow
for the intelligibility intelligibility
of cognitive component which is
intention which is motivation
context bring computer metaphors we have
neuro and cognitive activity often seen
as a transfer of symbolic information
and cognition then the snapshot of this
transfer so it's totally dependent of
that kind of symbolical transfer which
is really difficult to explain how
that's going to be biologically
plausible and there's a lot of effort
trying to do that so if you're
interested in this little there's a very
vast wealth of literature but they have
to answer to this problem so
cloud in my name brain needs to produce
an impromptu response to inputs of the
external environment all the time
and the idea of this formal semantics
the authors is trying to explain is
trying to include this component into
the model so you have a deflationary
model about content so you have a formal
semantics we have semantics without
content interestingly and formulated as
a variation of free
A variation free energy functional so
those structures
that embody those process correspond to
status states in the system name
and we also have the ecological
component
that can be
formalized in terms of these two
informational geometry that we
distribute densities do probabilistic
the density is one from the Dynamics and
one from the position describing
Behavior
and a lot so how can active influence be
compatible to biosynthetics can it be
actually compatible or is it even
necessary
well and
active inference is a very general
framework and then it does not really
give us
the tools to understand how encoding can
happen in terms of
symbols like how they can be
broadcasted into Collective action
because prediction alone does not
explain how do they come about so in
this sense
uh we do have meaningful correlations
that
refer to the Dynamics of one or two or
more systems in terms of information or
geometry
that needs to be cashed out with
predictive value so how is this
possible
well
we can talk about that in terms of
shared attention that's when one form of
these kind of model chip cache designs
so we have active inference capturing
relevance statistical relations between
environment and in aging and why
we uh why I'm trying to think about here
is how biosemiotics offer tools for this
informational sensitivities and in
statistical relations to catch symbols
in terms of use an interpretation
within communities of language users
about
and that can only happen in the sense
via directed action so the problem now
will turn you to how is it possible to
specify the factors that are sufficient
to constrain action and directed into
specific
um
about is European forestry I'm picking
this example from a very important like
a stage from chain disc
I really recommend kind of thing tells
the story about how coordinated action
how stage coordinates specific
Collective actions but that's not the
point that I want to talk here so
here let's unfold that a little bit in
terms of the design of scientific
forestry and think about scientific
forestry as a practice
and a practice that has an organizing
principle
that we will like
um well that will
be the main important uh articulating
story The can
connect together how agriculture layouts
plantations in specific ways and how
Collective Collective firms will make
specific choices in terms of this
organization and how Villages can
structure themselves around one specific
notion or one specific organizational
principle
and how everything can be calculated to
make
once one type of practice which is
agriculture is a very general more
legible and more manipulable
or
different kinds of communities so in
that we will involve manipulating the
very concrete aspects of the land the
terrain the products the workforce so it
has a very encompassing effect
over time and in a very concrete
in a very concrete sense
and interestingly when you talk about
European forestry and how how European
forestry was modeling the terrain and
how it's catching out value of these
terrains they were not trying to do that
to successfully depict the full range of
diversity of the actual social activity
and also the actual activity of
Agriculture or the richness of the
vegetation or they are not even trying
they didn't intend to do that that was
not the point of this kind of
modeling turned into a practice right
those models generally represent
specific slices of nature that were
interesting for one specific official
Observer and
that point is really important because
that we
came how all these communities and how
the terrain and how the forest we won't
fold over time
within this specific perspective
so I bring here a quote that I really
really like because it tries to flesh
this out in simple terms and very useful
ones
so thinking that exaggerating only
slightly
one might say that the interest in
forests
was resolved true when Fisco
specific single number which was the
revenue that you from the timber that
was extracted annually
well that's okay that's understandable
like that's intelligible and that
happens with you every day in terms of
how we understand our economy but what
is interesting about this quote is like
the best way to appreciate
how heroic was this constriction of
vision is to notice what Falls outside
the field of vision
so what is missing from that is not the
the organizational principle of Timber
being valuable but everything that was
not there or was being excluded treason
bushes and Planters implants that hold
little to non-potential for that purpose
so missing out of that is Florida
diversity foliage fruits
Etc twigs and branches missing out of
that are insects and small animals
depending on this diversity oh this
ecological organization falls out
of the organizational principle and that
has very complete consequences that we
still suffer and we still live we live
in the
height of this
uh
climate crisis that also starts from
this kind of thinking so it has really
very material consequences for us and
had for them at the time if you read
more about it you know that a team
whereby like ex by streaming and
domesticating nature so much like
decreased in quality and then eventually
decreased in value which prompted them
to re to try to reorganize that kind of
story
and what do I want to call attention
with the example is that also to bring
some specific ways of talking about it
this brings vocabulary for that only
exists in terms of this type of practice
specifically so this vocabulary
constrains nature in a way by pruning
what can your cannot be used so it
generates more than illegible nature but
a way of making nature intelligible and
intelligible in a very specific certain
way and we make that happen in terms of
symbolizing things in specific terms but
the symbols they don't exist in
themselves they exist only in
organizing this social practice around
them so when you replace nature with a
term called natural resources we are
doing exactly that it's specifying from
a generalized notion of nature
like flora and fauna becomes something
valuable becomes a commodity
but not everything right it trims
the practice it separates competing
species from value glands so plants are
symbolized as crops
and what is or the competing species are
symbolized the weeds they are not
necessarily crops or weeds or anything
like that in nature but area that for
the way we talk like that because we
practice
agriculture in a certain way that also
help that's the same for insects or
small animals that consume these
interesting crops
so
the material effect of that and how that
only gains protection in the practice
over time and how you have specific
intention that has unintended
consequences uh are necessarily here
situated contextualized and embodied in
terms of trimming specific types of
attention and this attention will only
shift to reach to try to repopulate
insect population for instance when you
realize
that this practice like brought this
specific effect in a certain way
that affects the value of our
understanding of nature
and that generates expect exactly a type
of social coherence and social
coordination and
how constraints create these coherence
right
well
now let's talk back again like cement
about formal semantics while while these
formal semantics and active influence
sort of embeds one type of mathematical
formalism
uh
symbols can only be grounded
in a specific concrete practices or in
action
so while active inference can be used as
a tool to explain social understanding
it it does do that in terms of
generalized synchronization okay in a
model of cognition that can be inactive
and dynamic but is it still very general
in terms of biosematics we can
think of it as a framework that might be
compact compatible with active imprints
in terms of explaining the materiality
of the environment in a non-reductive
and a non-reductionist way that tries to
retain some naturalistic credentials
so how that conventions are affecting
and effecting the invited agent in terms
of forming those singles and cashing out
those epistemic values
and
well social interaction in this sense is
not reduced to prediction because in
this sense the prediction will not be a
primitive but it would print but it
would be a result of a specific
participatory construction of the social
scene
over a specific
uh organizational principles and actions
that
through the general through the
synchronization of this generative
models or the synchronization of those
agents that can be described in terms of
those generative models gain predictive
value and when you model that then you
have this type of understand the value
of prediction in those senses
so
that allows
that allows us to say that social actors
in distance can behave as if they have a
generative model that synchronizes with
that symbolic State of Affairs allowing
them to understand each other's
behaviors
or to develop approximate sales
informational sensitive or
responsiveness to the same symbols and
goals
they are approximate because they're
obviously not going to be the same but
they have a
they have an the same approximate
orientation
so in this sense we don't have ever a
view from nowhere we don't have ever
this view that is only
cast out in terms of specific types of
minds but you also have types of Mind
shaped in terms of this
very concrete organizations
that happens in a community like for
humans at least it happens in community
of language and users so the
relationship with a symbolic cues
helps to select attention
at that specific time as well pruning
what is what should be ignored is
socially constructed environments so
within a specific community of language
users some types of actions will be
desirable and will be deemed as true in
that specific type of community and can
be only evaluated under those terms
so you can provide reasons for actions
in that specific
in that specific context context and you
can talk about how
rational that action is in terms of the
conditions set by those communities
in
and that brings us to the idea that
human cognition in this sense is never
decoupled from this cultural
Norms that like pushes and orients them
over time
so you know scale of behavior and that's
the interesting thing and that's why
active inference can be an interesting
tool to
model this type of human communities and
this type of behavior
because it can come from the very
Dynamics the very basic of Dynamics to
specific types of perception and scale
up and more
so when you have the problem of symbols
like in these two decoupled
possible
community of users and symbols and
embodied agents and things that do not
combine we can try to
model our agents in a way that we don't
have this problem anymore because you're
trying to include that very
that very
[Music]
um
component into the model
so in the sense we have active inference
used as tools to explain social
understanding
as generalized synchronization
and in understanding others
in that sense because of this
generalized synchronization model tennis
assumed by
those types of
organizational principles
we can also engage in terms of Niche
construction so we have more or less
deterministic way of understanding
um
the nature of singles because the more
we interact and approximate synchronized
with the environment we change the
environment that might changes back so
you have
an open system that is always an
everywhere situated
and he can be modeled then with this
type of predictive value
so
that's more or less what I had in mind
and that's how I was trying to think
about biosemiotics and in a possible
relationship with um
free energy principle and the formalisms
of active inference
and yeah I think this is it
awesome thank you Lorena
I'll just
organize things a little in my room but
thank you very much for this excellent
lecture
um just as a kind of warm up
how did you come to see it this way
what what brought you to this general
question of semantics and how do you see
that like on your own path and see what
what other
comparable or analogous approaches have
been done in terms of a meta-analysis
and proposal related to the
Naturalization of semantics
uh I think it's kind of hard to
naturalize semantics right I think
there's a lot of effort in doing that
and it might be that if you think
differently about how we naturalize
those values
we might have better answers instead of
trying to
instead of trying to fit
gauge and into the model we try to fit
the model into the agent right I think
that's the move I think that was the
motivation I think the interesting the
interesting part of biosomatics in that
sense it tries to make less assumptions
when you're we will start from a
hardcore
assumption or model assumption right
that semantics is within only within the
mind then we have a very hard time
trying to explain that if you assume
less about that you might bring
different types of explanations of
course
but they might be very they'd be more
interesting that I was trying to like
see how that actually
how that looks like when you you bring
these two things together in in the
terms of active inference and free
energy principle if that works if that
is possible
I don't know if that answers your
question
so wondering about that fundamental
question and then coming across active
inference or how
elsewhere have people brought in the
more formal and Technical
into this question
um
what do you mean by Mar like formal and
can you repeat that please yeah how does
active inference help us or have
continuity or difference with previous
ways that people
have connected the technical part from
the um yeah what you described as the
formal semantics embeds the mathematical
formalism and then the symbols are
grounded in specific action so has that
been played out in other technical
Frameworks
well we do have technical Frameworks
that try to organize that in developing
activism right and auto poetic and
activism but then we just have in these
terms the notion of symbols uh sometimes
get
get Loosely described and I think these
guys are not really interested in that I
think they're trying to describe
something else for example or you can
have some specific types of
computational that like if you if you
really buy into the mind the
computational
brain and Temptation mind metaphor
then you have a hard time also to
explain how semantics are built in into
that computation right
I don't think anyone has a very strong
answer to that you have to really buy
into the idea of information processing
and that's something that that's what
brought me a little bit to that thing if
you buy into the metaphor of information
processing then you need to have
semantics within the brain if you try to
lose a little bit this notion if you try
to understand process and information in
different terms what happens
I think that was more or less the
question that I was trying to ask
an effective influence and by
semiotics can because they have less
assumptions in terms of what happens
inside the processing information
content in the mind
if that can if can if that can bring
interesting like answers or if you can
use as a model to organize Behavior
and
and there's another point that also
brought me a uh to
this type of thinking was
trying to understand
how active active inference can include
his historicity of the agent right
because I think that something comes
across
debated in active influence how you
bring novelty into the state space like
once you define that state space the
state space is more or less
deterministic
because everything will happen within
that specific range so how does an
object comes within
this type of uh modeling
so how can you explain that
if if it does I don't know it's more
like
it's it's more like an exploratory
question that I was trying to make and
see how that pans out I don't I actually
also don't have an answer for that but
if you take seriously this uh some more
inactive claims that you need history of
interactions to to understand how agents
behave you cannot understand agents
without that so
how does active inferences these
questions specifically
right because once yeah that system I
think that is still kind of debated I'm
not sure if there's new developments in
this specific topic but I remember I
think two years ago was like this
specific papers from the Paulo I think
the 4K laying down a path is
specifically focusing on that in the
formalisms and Etc so I don't know if
these two things can
bring a little bit of more
to the conversation maybe not
this great I'll just ask some some more
general questions you're adding a lot
with these thoughts so you said the
social interaction in this account is
not reduced to prediction
so how would you unpack that
and how would you relate this
I don't know exactly what term of art
would go here but this kind of social
epistemology that active inference
provides Us in contrast to say
predictive processing
so how is it that that we would or
wouldn't reduce something to prediction
and then what is it that active
inference brings into that discussion
yeah
oh I think I have two points in that
like active interest in that sense that
has like
out type of modeling that tries to
include all the time and everywhere the
embodied agent like if if you take
seriously the idea then the model
the genetic model is always accurately
modeling
that specific agent and because you can
it cannot be true or false that the
model is your current state like is like
that like even if you are not feeling
really well you just know that you're
not feeling well in relation to
something else and that
that story is still very accurate to
your stage condition right now
right so the prediction
you get instruction in socially at least
in that sense not in the specific detail
of like predictive predictive processing
you think because I think that's more
complicated but socially in social
cognition at least
we can talk about this predictive value
I think it's a more interesting way to
do that because
the mother the the example that I use in
terms of Cashing Out symbols we are
we're using some something that was
meant in
to make something intelligible that have
very bad consequences that were not even
close to be predicted
so in that sense and how these
consequences happen
don't prediction cannot be there
everywhere and all the time
the prediction in this has an
orientation as well right
so that gonna that's gonna unfold only
in terms of the orientation but that's
not all-encompassing
so well what does that say about the
prediction that's why I was trying to
think of it as not being a primitive but
something that comes along with this
Dynamics
but yeah
well this is a very deep impression
point that because the causal structure
of the world changes historiosity agents
change they learn
and they attend and then the niche
changes with stigma G and Niche
modification so because things really do
change Through Time
then just training a data set at one
time point
and then using that same generative
model and carrying it forward
it's like picking a speed in a direction
when you're on a Winding Road and just
saying all right now let's turn on
cruise control right now and just keep
going in this direction it's working
right now
um so then to connect that to the
legibility of the forests as the causal
model changed and externalities were not
taken into accountants and so on all
these different features you brought in
so now is active inference and cognitive
modeling cognitive Technologies
increasing our legibility
of perception cognition and action
through surveillance technology and
other mechanisms
such that there could be
slash we expect there to be
also
hidden Dynamics and externalities that
we are also failing to see when we make
some aspects of cognitive systems
legible
in the way that research in the
neurosciences is happening towards
yeah I think in the sense like if you
've got focuses everything right it
would be non-informative
in terms of what you do when you do that
you have one interested you're
interested in something right you have
one
thing in mind when you get your trying
to flesh out
in terms of cognitive modeling how that
so how that applies to these more own
compassing situations I think that's
like that model is how I'm trying to ask
this question so you can model them in
dislike sliced
sense and that's
that's what we that's what we do as
scientists and that's how we learn about
things
but that only way of seeing that that
very specific model does not all
encompassing for Owens or it's like so
how can you
how can you use that in comparison to
other situations so how can you
integrate this this type of thing I
don't know I really
I I don't have a question for an answer
for that I don't know if we do have an
answer for this
this type of
question currently but I think it's a
very valid question to ask
because because also in terms of
sometimes
applying that socially
that sort of revise in a way
and then it becomes someone organizing
principle that becomes somewhat reified
so keep an eye for this kind of
metaphorical use like assuming a little
bit that all this talk can be
metaphorical and it can be interesting
and useful to catch that catch them out
in these terms because they don't have
other ways to talk about them
so
how we don't reify them and how they are
in you know because
well I think I'm I'm getting I'm having
a hard time to get there but I think I
think I'm making the point of people
criticizing the cause of Primacy so you
when you reduce this complex systems to
one single cause cashing out everything
that organizes the principle this this
these complex systems and when Primal
cause
then you are losing the complexity
however if you don't do that
how can you slice it out you understand
the system so I think that's the two
tensions here that I'm kind of trying to
to to propose as a question in terms
instead of an insert
I don't know if that makes sense but I
think yeah I hope people continue that
discussion I'm going to build on that
just to kind of maybe circle around that
because it's really important so in the
forestry case
the the realist perspective again using
retro casting the way we or contemporary
discussions some of them in the active
inference and free energy principal
space are the realist says that region
of land is just economic potential it is
a natural resource that becomes a kind
of handle
the instrumentalist perspective takes a
step back and says it's as if that piece
of land is a natural resource so yeah
the territory is Indescribable and
there's still a space for mystery but
then when the proxies come out because
policies are being selected that as if
in some ways carries similar
consequences to the actual because they
and they may totally agree and the
realists and the and the
instrumentalists might be like yeah it
is an economic potential or represents
or it could be treated as such or it
could be engaged with as such like that
cognitive diversity can align on the
social policy
that then connects to these broader
social
questions and histories and so it's kind
of interesting like what work does this
instrumentalism do like oh it's just a
principle
what work does it do and what doesn't it
do and the ways that that science and
technical engineering fields are and
aren't deployed alone or together
with other considerations
yeah that's very interesting like in the
sense either if you're realist or
instrumentalist about that like if you
think like models are not either true or
false they're just models right they
might have views and you might they
might be capturing real properties but
the problem is in this conversation even
when you push them like you have
realized and have an instrumentalists
try to like loosen up a little bit these
assumptions
they still come they still not refine
those principles and taking them to be
more or less true or false
right well that's kind of plot twist
it's like you're appealing to what
surprise minimization as unifying
the diversity responses that the realist
and instrumentalists do so then does
that make surprise or cognitive inertia
like the ER principle where the maze
just ends and it explains itself or how
does that play in a pluralistic
scientific setting
yeah that's that that's you you you
might you can have a third answer to
that like right it has two
well I think the answer that I'm trying
to give is more eliminativist in the
sense that eliminates the cause of
Primacy of them of these two modes of
answering
so
when you think I'm thinking I have in
mind now like actually just to try to
make sense of that when you when you
think about biological information you
can think about biological information
has been where you were as being
metaphorical or instrumental or you have
these guys like Susan oyama or Richard
Levant in Detroit to bring some they are
against this cause of Primacy they try
to advocate for
systems that do have that but they have
like a lot of more going on so that
cannot be the only answer because those
systems is not everywhere
scientifically cash they don't have to
be everywhere
that so
for example going back to to the
forestry forestry so the realistic is
going to say that territory is valued
properly and the the
in the sense the instrumentalisticated
look as if you know can be he is as if
but it's not necessarily value property
it doesn't matter you can say like well
this terrain is
theme from one perspective as value
property but this also has other uses
around them so you had to be more
inclusive of this diversity because
this the only organization
principle around that specific terrain
is not
only to generate value or if it does
this value doesn't have one single
output it can have more than one output
in terms of
very specific terms you can catch it out
very maturely this terrain that has to
provide monoculture needs to also has to
provide also value for the diversity of
the fauna and the diversity the
diversity of the Flora around it and
that is not included in a model because
that's not what a model is done for the
model has a specific use and that's fine
however that does not reduce the terrain
to that
and well when you're talking about
cognition that might be more complicated
but I think it's easy it's an easy way
to talk about this causal Primacy when
you talk about uh forestry because we
are very much now experiencing this
climate crisis and we see these things
happening right now and how difficult
because this this type of thinking is
built over time in so well
fixed in the way we see things and we
are understanding how hard is to change
that it's not it's a it's a paradigm
shift that needs to happen for that to
change
is not necessarily the model that is
right or wrong it's just how you
understand and apply them
so
there are pragmatics into that it's not
only an instrumental but it has
something that the instrumentalists take
does not capture and I don't know how to
cast it out in a one single word but
that's what biosematics was offering by
semiatics was offering the idea of
practice in pragmatics I don't know if
it's
the whole story but it's another
Point into that story
a lot a lot of great points all all
connect that no of pragmatism to a
little bit of the active inference
formalism so when it comes to policy
selection Behavior selection some but
not all cognitive entities can act as if
they're calculating expected free energy
so these are the active the truly active
entities whether they're simple or
whether they're sophisticated they do
planning expected free energy is how
those agents are being modeled as if
they're making decisions and it consists
of the pragmatic and the epistemic value
that's how these different policies are
evaluated and so I see two
angles or windows that that supports
at least for my non social sciences
background a new kind of meeting in the
middle there
so first is the expansion of pragmatic
value under the principle that surprise
minimization or bounding is the
imperative
right there in the pragmatic value it
doesn't have to be just body temperature
or financial income we can expect and
prefer
ourselves to be learning new things or
meeting new people and so we can load
into the pragmatism
different goals that under a narrower
definition of utility or pragma have not
traditionally been included so I think
that first way
is it speaks to a more inclusive concept
of utility you might say I'm also
de-risking on forest fires alongside the
Timber and already you've had you have
now plural pragma so I think that's the
kind of crossover and then the deeper
and second and not saying there's only
two ways that that the conversation
continues we have epistemic utility
in terms of epistemic value
and so the balance and the weighting
between pragmatic value and epistemic or
learning oriented activity overall
helps control
a dynamic balance with just like how
tight is the grip and the preference
overall
and maybe we have uh some preference for
Timber to be exported from a region
but we really don't know we don't have
long-term modeling we don't have deep
causal analysis and so we're going to
put five percent on the pragmatic
extraction and other pragmatic features
and leave the rest of the policy in an
exploratory mode
and come to a blend that's not just on
the the Spectrum from explore to exploit
which is how this has been approached in
like cognitive Sciences previously it's
like this is the third thing where
policies that are on the frontier of
exploring and exploiting
rise to the top through their
contributions to pragmatic and epistemic
value and we made the model
so that isn't to say that that is what's
happening on the ground or maybe that's
just the instrumentalist perspective
yeah yeah
but if if it's an instrument an
instrumentless perspective might be a
good one right in the sense the idea of
inclusion is kind of the interesting one
right because if you really find a
destination of maximization because you
can use that in certain ways to
understand what happens within when
you're modeling something what is the
limit of that maximization so that's you
can model agents as if maximizing
utility for instance
for maximizing utility is something that
needs to be balanced out with utility of
everyone around them right
and that's not that's not trivial how
that happens right and even if it does
and even if it were trivial it's not
something that
Maps out completely
identically with all every single agent
they don't that's not that's not going
to be there's going to be diversity
there so how do you make that notion
more inclusive and less verified in that
sense because then if the more you
refine the more you single it out into
around only
one General type of understanding so
when you think them more individually
then you kind of lose you lose that
strength of this one single
principle
organized like the one single way of
Cashing Out fertility that's not the
principle right sorry
so I think that's like speaks a lot of
lightning
the type of
instrumental use and the type of
pragmatism and how
the time the types of application of
this
practices right remember in the in the
sense
of the scientific forestry it's also a
practice it's not something that is true
in itself
it's true in terms of practice right in
terms of applications in terms of
building communities around them so
without this use they have no grounding
yeah one
really strong and Salient point that I
got from the lecture was about
generalized synchrony
and it's almost funny that we have to
Advocate or delineate generalized
synchrony because the alternative the
absence of generalized synchrony
is just like kind of like an ideal gas
it's like there wouldn't be regularities
in society we wouldn't be clustered in
space or in time we wouldn't have
information and communication and
we wouldn't have
what differentiates
a society or a group or civilization or
a colony or whatever from literally
anything else
so generalized synchrony is almost like
all of the space between nothing and
anything happening
and then it supports all these different
scenarios we could have
this kind of mind in this kind of brain
in this kind of environment this kind of
Niche and so we can talk about the ant
colony foraging algorithms that work in
the desert
and there might be mutual
non-exhausted
open-ended change of algorithms and what
works in a different setting
and with humans we have
the sophistication and the history
and the scope and the scale and all of
these metas and weaving with is an ought
and our own forward going
Direction
which is really the moment where it goes
from being a forensic
sociology
to the real time sense making
an action selection based upon
our cognitive models in the broader
sense which includes humans and
non-human agents but it's like that's
when it goes from being more than just
an understanding when that understanding
translates to an action policy and they
do
then
it matters as much as anything does
yeah well one of the criticism of the
active information I think is too
General to single out
specific constraints that Orient action
right
that's what I saw like thinking about
how symbols
uh
brought about in community of Youth
language users
assuming that the symbols are not they
they are only meaningful throughout this
histories and practices
can help us to apply this type of
General story
right yeah
navigating specific uh
well epistemic communities and I think
like that's the work that my whole is
going to bring along in terms of
epistemic communities and then you
single out in them so you have these
communities of
language users in which specific
practices
create a specific orientations
yeah one thought on that
asking like what is
uh active inference or linear regression
or some other method again this is who
knows is this just deep esoteric
instrumentalism but asking what does it
have to say about this symbol what is
what does active inference have to say
about the letter E in English
can it be as simple as to say that
that's a category error and that you
could make a toy example or a
pedagogical example where symbol one and
symbol two awesomely in a multi-agent
simulation or you could make a
generative model for an alphabet and
leave it abstract but you're never going
to connect to the historiosity and the
real enactment of the English letter e
unless you're confronting
that my new particulars and the actual
embodiment of that letter
and then there's different course
screenings different iterated modeling
decisions different questions about how
do you include and participate in a
different stage of the scientific
process but it's like you're in the
specifics at that point
active inference doesn't have an opinion
on the letter e because we wouldn't want
it to it would be too opinionated about
the wrong things it'd be making
assumptions
and bringing axioms into play that would
be extremely constraining
and so it
remains General as a framework and the
free energy principle even more slash
differently so but when we get into the
actual that's where we're connecting to
the real systems of interest but how how
can we make claims
and Advance them socially about systems
of Interest
when we're not even it's like comparing
bridge building as a concept with this
bridge right here
it's a little bit like a a category
disconnect
yeah
well it depends on also how you single
out some things they are not they're
just you just don't do that because
they're just not interesting enough
right there's nothing like that comes
out of it
in terms of this bridge right here in a
single
how did you put it again like
your category of bridges in this bridge
right here right when you do that you
can learn something about a category in
terms of this single one right here
why does not it's not exhaustive
that's it that's the thing one point
it's not exhaustive and it's not right
or wrong it might be better than
other I think they did like you can
bring some com you can make some
comparisons in terms of like predictive
value you can have like better or worse
ways of doing it and then it gains more
utility
okay connecting this to also
um this this non-exhaustive nature and
where the power of a generalizable
framework is let's talk about the
category of Golden Gate bridges in San
Francisco
so there's only one actual Bridge there
but we're generalizing it and so
somebody makes a state space and says
well I'm exploring if there was more
than two end to end so they're exploring
the state space of topology is a bridge
and someone else is exploring the state
space of color and somebody else is
exploring the state space of traffic
Dynamics and someone else is combining
two of them or combining all three of
them
and then that's the conversation is
which map of this category of State
spaces
category of adjacent possibles as we
chose to model it
and if you don't include traffic flow
don't be surprised that it's not going
to take that kind of data or make that
kind of prediction and some variables
matter and some matter in combination
and some don't but when we model we kind
of build these
regions or adjacencies to the actual
which is where the historiosity of the
past leaves us
and then we have an adjacent possible as
modelers and sense makers
including absurd counterfactuals and
state spaces
and then the state spaces are mobilized
yeah in a way but if you talk about like
specific type of engineering yes in that
since they are mobilized and they are
not true or false you can use false
models that is to function that's not
like you can you have specific uses of
things that you know they're not really
true like the thing the tolerate
caloric type of modeling the uh
social uh the solar system is to use
that to navigate you know in the desert
even though it's not really accurate but
if you want to go from A to B it helps
you to do that
that's
the different thing right like it
doesn't it's not true or false but when
you think about agents in terms of like
and if bringing back to the idea of uh
symbols being only cashed out in terms
of community fuses that have histories
and
and they they are made useful they're
made meaningful in terms of their
practices
then you you don't have ever this
disconnect actually right you have a
cover you can think about this cognition
as always connected so there's a
specific types of practicing you can
even single out some moments of it
and try to see what you learn from this
kind of slides of time
but when you think about the whole story
of the cognitive system
you can if you're gonna really think of
it in terms that
is valuable you cannot disconnect from
the state let's say the legislate space
of it
s practice
awesome well so
do you have any closing
[Music]
thoughts or what are you looking forward
to with the discussion section the rest
of the course just by way of wrapping up
and letting people know any other
thoughts
yeah
we go to explore this this idea that
we've been actually bringing along here
right how we can go with that like
instrumentally a realistically or how
can we understand this General
synchronization of the model in terms of
specific
instantiations and how
formative they are is that really
interesting or
how candies things be actually refined
in terms of
modeling and if that happens does that
have any specific consequences actually
or not right maybe not
awesome well
very ambitious and excellent lecturer so
thank you very much lerna and yeah just
yeah just keep in mind it was just I was
just like trying to ask these questions
I don't also have those answers like
it's I I found very little about active
inference and semiotics like produced I
found like a few papers so that's very
exploratory actually so yeah so we're
invited to think of these things and
explore a little bit then further if
it's possible yeah
oh epic all right
thank you Laura see you in a couple of
weeks farewell see you bye